it's great to welcome bob kuttner to the
program today who is co-editor of the
american prospect magazine
also chair at the heller school for
social policy and management
at brandeis university i really
appreciate your time today thanks for
being on
pleasure to be with you so i've been
interested in in the idea of economic
nationalism for some time
and one of the i guess where we can
maybe start is whether there is some
inconsistency among some on the left on
this issue because
i'm still developing sort of my my sense
of this but
there is a sort of uh global
egalitarianism
that i see from many who like me
describe themselves as being on the left
and progressives
that seems to stop short when it comes
to well we should have an economy that
prioritizes
the american worker we should have trade
deals that are best for
the united states is there a conflict
or an inconsistency there not
necessarily
and i think it's it's really important
to start out by defining what we mean
and i think economic nationalism means
two different things that sometimes get
uh conflated rather sloppily so good
let's start with that
please so if you are a roosevelt
progressive
and you're not a neo-liberal and you
think that
capitalism is predatory and in order to
have a system that is efficient
and socially just the government has to
be
involved big time a democratic
government has to be involved big time
in regulating capitalism
that means that you have to put limits
on globalism
because if you have what we've had for
the past 30 or 40 years with wto
and the use of trade deals to undercut
the regulation of capitalism
you can't regulate capitalism i mean
banks can go offshore
and uh we don't care whether
products that we import are made with
slave labor you you know the whole
litany
sure so economic nationalism in one
sense of the word
simply means that we have to regulate
capitalism
and we for better or worse is the nation
state there's no global economy you
can't
regulate uh capitalism with the republic
of nafta
you have to regulate it with the united
states of america where where i'm a
citizen and you're a citizen
and to some degree is that also just the
practicality of
uh legal framework and and just sort of
the the limits of what
any one group can do i mean i know we
have we have nato we have w
you know we have these organizations but
it does get sloppy
well it's about sovereignty yeah if you
want to try and regulate capitalism
you you need a degree of sovereignty and
the state is sovereign
um and uh there is no sovereignty
globally except to the extent that you
have treaties
right the other kind of economic
nationalism
of which trump is the extreme example or
maybe hitler's the more extreme example
is america first or germany first and
screw the rest of the world
and so where it gets tricky is on the
question of how you
make it possible for the whole world to
regulate capitalism
in the interest of ordinary people and
uh
since we don't have a global government
that means you have to have agreements
you have to have treaties this morning's
new york times reports that
the eu is going to have climate tariffs
if you if you try to export stuff uh
into the eu that uh
are made with processes and products
that pollute
you're gonna have to pay a tariff now
that's a good kind of nationalism
and um biden's talking about doing the
same thing
so the tricky part for me anyway
because i'm you know i'm a third world
guy as well as a new dealer
how do you extend this so that the whole
world is able to regulate predatory
capitalism
and interestingly um that is what was
attempted in 1944 at the bretton woods
conference
where the architect of that conference
was john maynard keynes he got a do-over
uh you know they got it wrong at the
treaty of versailles in
uh in 1919 where he was a junior
economic advisor to the british
government
he quit in disgust in protest
and then 25 years later he was the chair
of the bretton woods conference and he
said
we have to orchestrate the rules of the
global system
so that every country gets to regulate
capitalism
in the interests of workers in the
interest of citizens
now here's the tricky part you get down
to cases
so if we think that china is predatory
we we think that china violates human
rights we think that
china violates the rules of the trading
system where they subsidize and they
dump and they uh steal intellectual
property and all that stuff
and um so we're going to have some
we're going to have an industrial policy
and we're going to have a national
security policy where
certain technologies we're not going to
allow china to acquire
that seems pretty sensible to have an
industrial policy where do you draw the
line
and is that an industrial policy for the
united states or is that an industrial
policy that the eu
and all of the democracies are part of
and then if that's
the case um who gets the business so for
instance um there are three major
chip companies that are not chinese that
make state-of-the-art ships
one's intel the other two are european
ericsson and nokia
so do you have a cartel do you carve up
the market
or do you say we have one set of rules
for companies that
play by you know democratic norms and
and market norms and a different set of
rules for china which doesn't play by
market norms so
where it gets tricky is around the edges
where when you get down to cases
and here's vietnam a
third world country a dictatorship but
not as nasty a dictatorship as china
and a lot of stuff gets outsourced to
vietnam
by american companies and these are very
poor people who need the work
this is where it gets tricky and uh so
you have to have trade agreements that
are very different
from the kind of trade agreements that
clinton and obama made
that have human rights in them that have
some concern for the ability of third
world countries to get
a foot on the ladder so that they can
have decent living standards for their
for their people
but not simply turning the world over to
multinational corporations
yes and i wanted to i mean let's talk a
little bit about trade if we can because
um the the the concept of free trade
being a net positive is rooted in some
pretty traditional economic ideas of
specialization and relative efficiencies
of
of producing and exporting products and
it really goes back to a lot of that
that traditional economics uh and
at at the end of the day as you're
pointing out sometimes the best way
to control conditions when it comes to
labor
and products and imports is you bring
the you bring the supply lines domestic
uh but at the same time then you're
depriving as you point out
a lot of people around the world uh of
the ability to better themselves and
better better their economic situation
so how how would
how should we interpret all of that and
sort of parse it yeah
let me address what you said about trade
being efficient
and then let me respond to the second
question yeah well here's a conundrum
you know david ricardo etc uh theory of
comparative advantage yep
trade is efficient because of
specialization okay but hold on
we have known ever since roosevelt and
before really
that free markets are not efficient
right markets price things wrong
markets priced carbon wrong um
lord nicholas stern said global climate
change is history's
epic case of market failure right um
markets price labor wrong because
corporations have the power to really
exploit workers
markets price all kinds of stuff wrong
they price housing wrong
um so question how is it that
we need to have a managed form of
capitalism domestically
because markets price things wrong and
then somehow when you cross borders
all of a sudden markets price things
right and the answer is they don't
and um this gets into power
relationships
uh you you want third world countries to
be able to
uh get jobs and and gain market share
but you don't want them to exploit their
workers so let me give you an example of
a trade deal that i think was a pretty
good trade deal yeah
um there used to be something called the
multi-fiber agreement
it was a worldwide cartel for textiles
and apparel
and the idea was that um we're going to
give every
country that wants to export uh textile
products into the united states
a quota and the economist said this is
terrible this is a cartel this violates
the free market and the other side of
the argument was well if you
if you just eliminate it china will get
everything
because china will underprice everybody
and all these other countries will get
the short end of the stick common
argument huh
commonly heard commonly repeated yes so
what they did for a while this was in
the last two years of clinton when bob
rice was secretary of labor
and actually had some influence they
made they made
an agreement cambodia was the model
country and the agreement
was if if you follow
international labor organization norms
and you give workers the right to
organize
we will give you uh additional
quota slots under the multi-fiber
arrangement
and so thanks to that
the labor movement got a foothold in
cambodia
and workers actually started being paid
better it didn't hurt their market share
it helped their market share
and then of course the republicans come
in and they just blow away the whole
thing
so there's a middle ground i guess this
is my punchline yeah
there's a middle ground between
absolutely free trade which is a mirage
anyway
and um trumpian economic nationalism
which is a kind of negotiated trade
where you have some norms where you have
some standards
and the standards are not just a covert
way of screwing the third world
and a lot of the third world diplomats
have made the argument
that the west is hypocritical the west
uh
talks about the international labor
organization talks about labor standard
that's just protectionist and again you
got to get down to cases
depending on the particular rules that
are negotiated it can be protectionist
or it can be in the interest of workers
everywhere so you have the case of the
bangladesh
horrible bangladesh fires where
this is a very poor country
the job so that workers don't die in
fires but you don't do that as a covert
way of depressing their market share
you've got to get down to cases i guess
that's the point the last thing i wanted
to touch on briefly
relates to the coronavirus pandemic
we've talked to economists social
psychologists all sorts of different
folks about
uh the impacts that they see as a result
of the coronavirus pandemic and and what
we've sort of learned
learned from it when it comes to an
economic nationalism perspective
globalization supply chains etc what do
you see as the big takeaways from the
pandemic
well i think and it's not just the
pandemic i mean the the the
fortunate thing about the pandemic is
that it it moves this
center stage and gets people talking
about it so i think
um it demonstrated that
reliance on supply chains
a lot of which are in countries who are
not necessarily our friends
is risky economically and risky
politically the question
is which stuff do we want to make in the
united states for what reasons
we want to make it in the united states
for industrial policy
and technological leadership and jobs
reasons
do we want to make in the united states
for national security reasons and where
do we draw the line
take take up solar cells uh
america was once the leader in solar
solar panels
china basically undercut america's
pricing
stole a lot of technology they're now
the leader if we take it back
uh try to take it back with an
industrial policy that means we're
paying more money in the short run for
solar panels right which
more expensive if we're trying to get a
bit of carbon
so it's complicated you cannot settle
this at the level of brand theory
you have to have some basic norms we
want a positive sum gain
that helps uh american workers and also
helps the third world
and then you got to get very specific
yeah and often i think that
missing from the conversation where we
hear just this very
vague in general bring the production
back home
there's very little discussion of the
impact that that would have on the
prices of many of the things that we're
talking about as you point out with
solar panels which
is a decision that could be made i mean
the decision could be made here's a list
of 10 areas where
we believe it's worth paying more here's
how much
access would be reduced for the american
people as a result of that but we
believe it's worth it
well and by the way this is what japan
and korea
and china all did at earlier stages of
their economic development
i mean a ricardian economist would have
said to the japanese
why in the world do you want to invest
in an auto industry or a steel industry
or a machine tool industry
because you can get it cheaper from the
united states and the japanese answer
was well it depends on what your time
horizon is
if your time horizon is this year yeah
but if your time horizon is 50 years or
100 years or a thousand years
we want that industry in our country
because that's good for our economic
growth and for our jobs
so you you can't just take a snapshot at
a point in time
and look at the china price look at the
u.s price and say oh well obviously
we got to buy from china so it really
it's
it's it's it's tricky it's complicated
and you've got to get
you've got to get into the details in
the particulars without question without
question we've been speaking with bob
cuttner who's co-editor of the american
prospect
also chair at the heller school for
social policy and management at brandeis
university
i really appreciate your time today and
your insights thanks so much for having
me